[Música]
y con nuestro primer invitado el día
vamos a hablar de lo ocurrido en Brasil
el pasado Domingo 8 de enero cuando
miles de partidarios del expresidente
brasileño Yair bolsonaro asaltaron el
congreso la residencia y el supremo
tribunal de ese país causando destrozos
en la sede de los tres poderes del
estado que se encuentran en Brasilia la
capital de esa nación analizamos
entonces las implicaciones de lo
ocurrido con Gustavo cgre él es analista
político internacional socio de segre y
Asociados Gustavo muy buena mañana de
martes Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de France 24 y le
pregunto cómo vio usted lo ocurrido en
Brasil este pasado Domingo 8 de enero un
peligro para la democracia de ese país
Cuál es la gravedad de lo ocurrido
muy grave buen día Y gracias por la
invitación en realidad tiene que ver con
no saber perder por parte de algunos
militantes de la derecha que
inconformados con la victoria del
presidente actual Lula Silva
intentaron hasta ese día 8 manifestar
pacíficamente su descontento en la
puerta de algunos cuarteles solicitando
la intervención de las fuerzas armadas
lo que claramente no es un acto
constitucional no obstante estar
previsto en la Constitución de Brasil la
eventual participación de las fuerzas
armadas el motivo por el cual se
solicitaban no era el correcto y no se
sabe muy bien si había infiltrados que
generaron estos actos de violencia a
partir de una manifestación que
pretendía ser pacífica o la cosa se fue
de control Lo cierto es que esto no es
bueno para la sociedad democrática debe
ser censurado los responsables deben ser
procesados Y seguramente penalizados por
la justicia
Solamente los que participaron sino
también los que financiaron porque había
mucha gente que venía del interior y
esto seguramente con un gasto de
traslado que alguien ha pagado Gustavo
hablando de culpas Cuál es el papel del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro en todo esto
evidentemente vimos en su cuenta de
Twitter un mensaje
rechazando de alguna manera estas
manifestaciones pero nada más que ese
pequeño mensaje en su cuenta de Twitter
el ex presidente bolsonaro se encuentra
en este momento hospitalizado en un
hospital de Orlando en Florida en
Estados Unidos por acusaciones
abdominales debido al apuñalamiento pero
digamos Cuál es el cuál ha sido el rol
de bolsonaro en lo que pasó el 8 de
enero no no se observa vínculo directo
ni fomento ni incitación a la violencia
por parte del expresidente Sí no hay
nada en concreto de hecho la justicia no
lo está colocando como responsable de
este hecho lo que sí existe son más de
mil personas que están detenidas
la situación por las cuales están
detenidas no es muy claras según algunos
videos hay niños inclusive entre los
detenidos algo que es desde el punto de
vista de los Derechos Humanos bastante
contradictorio y ahora hay que aguardar
el procedimiento de la justicia
recordemos que el presidente Lula
determinó la intervención Federal del
Distrito Federal la capital de Brasil
Esto fue ayer aprobado por cámara de
diputados va hoy al senado de la nación
debe ser aprobado también y será
intervenida hasta el día 31 de enero por
otro lado el ministro de la Corte
Suprema de moraes resolvió la
destitución provisoria Por 90 días del
gobernador del Distrito Federal y quien
Hoy está a cargo de la gobernación una
señora la vicegobernadora ya pidió junto
con otros diputados que sea colocado un
juicio político en el gobernador
destituido Así que es un complicador muy
grande para un país que está dividido
claramente una politización muy crítica
desde el punto de vista de quien ganó Y
quién perdió y el Tribunal Superior
electoral no colabora con eso porque
siguen existiendo dudas sobre el fraude
que estaría muy bueno que de alguna
manera estas de estas dudas sean
retiradas para que aquel que perdió se
quede tranquilo que perdió porque hubo
un acto democrático donde la mayoría
eligió otra opción claro hablando de
instituciones cómo queda Gustavo tras
este golpe a la democracia el pasado 8
de enero la institucionalidad de Brasil
históricamente ha sido una institución
es fuertes en ese país
Si siguen siendo fuertes No hay ninguna
posibilidad de golpe de estado sin que
las fuerzas armadas intervengan no
existe esa posibilidad Sí y las fuerzas
armadas no han intervenido no tienen
ninguna participación Entonces no se
puede aducir a golpe de estado esto ha
sido un acto de vandalismo como también
fueron realizados en el 2006 2013 y 2017
con igual exactos dañinos al patrimonio
público y privado por parte de
militantes de la izquierda cuando el
gobierno era de la izquierda también y
en ese momento en ninguna situación el
gobierno de Lula en la época y de Dilma
luego lo trataron como un intento de
golpe de estado la diferencia es que en
aquel momento la ruptura estaba a cargo
de quienes eran parte del gobierno
entonces eran un acto vandálico en este
caso se trataba de un golpe porque era
de la oposición hablamos de un país
totalmente polarizado como Bien también
lo estaba señalando Gustavo sobre todo
creció esta brecha tras estas elecciones
donde volvió al poder el que fuera ex
presidente ahora presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula Silva en un país en estas
condiciones políticas
están tan diferentes como está la
gobernabilidad de Lula en lo que le
queda Prácticamente todo su mandato por
delante no es fácil El problema es que
ha conseguido elegirse presidente con
una alianza muy grande de partidos a los
cuales Ahora hay que repartir caja para
que estén todos contentos y felices y
eso provocó que de 23 ministerios tenga
que aumentar para 37 ministerios eso
genera un claro aumento del gasto
público y Brasil va a pasar de un
superávit fiscal en el 2022 del 0,4% del
producto bruto interno para un déficit
fiscal de cuarenta mil millones de
dólares en el 2023 de hecho las primeras
actividades económicas no han sido
satisfactorias la bolsa de valores de
Brasil el ibobespa de San Pablo perdió
el equivalente a 100 mil millones de
dólares desde que Lula fue colocado como
presidente y específicamente las
acciones de la empresa Estatal petrobras
de petróleo han perdido desde que Lula
asumió el gobierno dos mil millones de
dólares Entonces es complicado poder
encajar dentro de una propuestas social
como ha sido la de Lula con recursos que
estaban bien en el 2022 pero que están
exigidos en el 2023 y que esto
seguramente va a generar inflación de
hecho en el medio de todo este acto
vandálico la los combustibles aumentaron
el 20% y esto genera inflación Pero
obviamente nadie habló de eso sino de
los actos de destrucción en el congreso
en la Corte Suprema y en la casa de
gobierno volviendo a esas imágenes que
todos vimos el pasado 8 de enero estos
actos vandálicos por parte de algunos
que estaban dentro de esta manifestación
Cómo pueden ocurrir estas cosas en unos
edificios que se suponen ser
extremadamente custodiados no y con una
seguridad reforzada por tratarse
del seno digamos del ejecutivo brasileño
Por qué ocurren este tipo de cosas y y
también no sé Gustavo si podemos hacer
algún tipo de comparación también con lo
ocurrido con la toma del Capitolio por
puesto que evidentemente salió a la luz
también en estado lo que pasó en Estados
Unidos el pasado 6 de enero del año 2021
y yo te diría que Esto ocurrió por un
descuido de las autoridades por eso
están siendo investigadas por eso ha
sido desplazado el gobernador y
exonerado el secretario de seguridad
las informaciones que nosotros manejamos
con audios que hemos escuchado de El
subsecretario de seguridad que le
informaba al gobernador en el momento
que eran una manifestaciones pacíficas
que la Policía Militar estaba
acompañando los manifestantes y habían
ocurrido otras manifestaciones
totalmente pacíficas por eso se
desconoce si esto fue organizado por los
propios bolsonaristas si hubo
infiltrados como ellos mismos seducen y
empezaron estos desmanes y obviamente a
partir de alguien que rompe siempre hay
gente que se pliega a esta ruptura este
acto vandálico como se ven en las
imágenes respecto de si es comparable
con la toma del Capitolio Yo te diría
que no porque los motivos eran
diferentes los días eran diferentes Esto
fue un domingo no había ningún tipo de
actividad dentro de lo que es la
actividad política de hecho ni el propio
Lula estaba en Brasilia y ha sido una
una culminación de una falta de
paciencia de mucha gente pero de una
forma muy descontrolada y totalmente
censurable claro también Gustavo desde
el punto de vista del juego político el
ahora presidente Luis Ignacio Lula Silva
pudiera utilizar esto a su favor Es
decir para poder tratar de unir a este
país tan polarizado del cual estamos
hablando evidentemente el rechazo
también de la violencia por parte de
muchos seguidores del expresidente Jair
bolsonaro pueden verse de alguna manera
como guiados o apoyara al presidente
Lula en ese sentido de la violencia
específicamente Cómo puede usar esto
Lula Silva a su favor
Lula es un [__] viejo de la política y
seguramente va a tratar de hacerlo ya lo
ha hecho ahí vemos una una imagen de la
Asunción y una imagen muy parecida se
vio cuando Lula junto con el presidente
de la cámara de diputados del senado y
la Corte Suprema bajaron nuevamente la
rampa por la cual subió para asumir como
presidente demostrando que la democracia
estaba fuerte pero dudo mucho que
alguien que simpatiza con bolsonaro y
que puede estar contrario a este tipo de
actitudes que no las aceptan porque es
Pacífico puede apoyar a Lula por esta
situación lo que se entiende es que
aquel que debe hacer penalizado lo haga
sea penalizado por la justicia pero de
ahí apoyar a Lula por esta situación lo
veo muy distante De cualquier manera
también hay que aguardar no sea que la
teoría de los infiltrados proceda hay
muchos detenidos La policía tiene
imágenes está trabajando inclusive con
ADN para identificar a quienes han roto
y robado patrimonio público Y de esa
forma en poco tiempo esperamos se
conozca la verdadera situación hay un
ministro Marcos dobal Perdón un senador
Marcos Duval que dice que el ministro de
justicia y que el propio Lula sabían por
informaciones de inteligencia que esto
podía ocurrir y ellos permitieron que
esto ocurra si esto fuera verdad le
generaría un efecto Boomerang a Lula y a
su ministro en la carencia de haber
tomado alguna medida cuando sabían que
esto podía ocurrir